hello hey it's happening please
yes we're live hello hey everybody how's
it going
we're lives whoo
[Laughter]
we are gonna play half-life Alex please
for the light stardom the stream it has
been a heck of a morning for me trying
to get to yourself right I just spent
literally all day yesterday making sure
my VR was all set just to play it and
that wasn't for streaming and then
everything broke you literally had a
sensor blow up yesterday we're gonna
we're gonna start this game up I'm also
writing to this current issue where it
just won't go fullscreen for me anymore
which is really weird because when I
played it earlier it did go fullscreen
and I don't know why anyway we're gonna
I'm gonna get this set up yeah it's it's
it's a monumental task to do a VR stream
as it is and then now we're trying to do
one with a remote setup which is even
wildly cuz we're all still quarantined
over here of course yeah we're not we're
not in the same room nope they're my
control
oh I can hear an infinite loop cool cool
that's when you know it's it's it's
definitely like good to go yeah it's
really just just booting dude dude what
do did you do loop why am I getting that
yeah uh it's kind of crazy that we've
got a new half-life game I played two
hours of it and I'm still kind of like
trying to wrap my head around it I
really like it and it's been giving me
kind of like half-life 2 feelings while
I'm because before it was like ah can
pick up boxes and chairs and in cans and
throw them back at the combine but now I
can like physically pick them up it's
it's like the same kind of ideas but
just kind of feeling like they're fully
realized and fleshed out now that I can
like properly interact with all of them
totally okay yeah I don't think anyone
else can hear the game okay hold on one
second ooh ooh we're getting somewhere
yeah we're getting somewhere
Reis calling out your your steam name Oh
Stardust Crusaders is that a Joe Joe
reference you better bet oh I think I
figured out why I'm getting duplicate
doctors me hellooo Oh No Oh got it
looking we figured it we're in we're in
oh we're in then I love it
I'm gonna want my say I'm gonna do I'm
gonna turn my monitor so that you guys
can see just some degree oh you're gonna
give them the full the full VR treatment
I'm gonna try to this is what happens
when you do everything at home yeah yeah
okay I'm going in Zeb says that they
appreciate our dedication during all
this time that you know things have been
kind of crazy it's it's what we try to
do we try to try to give you guys
something to like I don't know we do it
for you yeah this is something that kind
of ground ourselves because we all need
to kind of have the people most of the
people at home okay yeah it's good that
we can we can do this kind of stuff
we're here we're in it we're doing it
saying you are room-scale
holy crap I didn't realize you had like
I have space man look at my apartment
Yeager Rudi's I'm over here like oh I
can I can sit on my bed if I want to
because it takes up half of what I said
is my room scale but yeah you've got
like a like a a proper rug with like
segmented areas too it's yeah the bright
side it really easy to like build the
room scale damn then you'll have to if
there's any adjustments I need to make
him to chat or making the on the stream
audio or whatever you just let me know
if anyone if we need to adjust audio
yeah let look let me know I'll let John
Luke know I'm watching chat I'm hanging
out he's playing I'm tightening my
headset he's tightening his headset
but yeah it's an all morning but I
finally confessed ah so yeah my like
base station exploded yesterday which
was a lot of fun yeah this looks [ __ ]
awesome yeah hold on uh I did just throw
a can at that pigeon hey you gotta do
what you gotta do alright so I'm using
the UM use the teleporter for moving uh
Bob saying the game seems like it might
be low but there's also not too much
sound happening right now bump it a
little bit hold on hey can you can you
adjust all that stuff from inside VR cuz
that was the thing I learned about today
cuz I can do it with oculus um maybe
maybe maybe not here one sec I was also
like I had my phone sitting next to me
so I was able to hear if I heard a slack
notification go off I'd be able to pull
up like slack and check it in a window
while I was still in VR so that was real
fun
okay I boosted game volume a little bit
sweet hopefully it helps you guys out
alright let's uh let's just mess around
this thing man so I got the index
controllers here by the way I'm playing
with a vibe but I can use because it
runs on the same like Steam architecture
you can you can use like the the index
controllers which is honestly my new
favorite way to like use VR these
controllers are so cool because you have
like the individual hand movement so I
can do this there's a lot of fun he's
there Ben yes okay I wasn't sure if I
lost oh I'm so I'm still going back and
forth because I've still got my my lunch
and I'm trying to like mute my
microphone to no hear me I'm being slick
about it I'm checking the radio got
tuned their frequency in so BMX no chat
brings up a good point where it's it
doesn't almost like do it enough justice
to actually watch this no it really it
really doesn't so like I I cut the video
review for Michael which you should go
check out by the way it's a very good
review and playing it I was just like
man this game looks cool
actually being in it is a completely
different experience it's it's wholly
wholly different which makes me really
excited to get to like some headcrab
stuff which won't we do that oh uh
apparently your mouse cursor is kind of
on the screen oh no if that's the thing
you want yeah let me fix that
hold on yeah we don't we don't need that
don't won that get that get that out of
there there we go got you guys we guys
what am i what am i eating a sausage
because it was cheap and I was able to
get it before everything locked down
okay you want that as Murr eating you
don't not when I eat it's disgusting
it's a real and real mess also you won't
be able to hear all the story but I'm
definitely gonna be talking oh I should
put on subtitles for people oh
definitely do that yeah sorry let's
let's take care of that right now
sorry I don't really I'll be able to see
them but I assume you guys definitely
will is that show not for you oh yeah
there they are yeah yeah can I have some
food I totally forgot it like what time
was lunch and I was like I should
probably take my my lunch break oh wait
it's two o'clock
oh wait I'm supposed to be on a stream I
did ask you last minute I'm very sorry
about that no you're fine gave me a
heads up before and I just it just
slipped my mind I got in the zone
processing trailers for gamespot.com
are you guys seeing the text the same
way I'm seeing it or is it more static
oh it's like visually appearing in front
of me like or as for you guys does it
look normal because I know it it's in
front of you and it moves with your head
oh it does okay so I'll try to be
careful then yeah so it'll readjust
anytime you stop moving but yeah
[Music]
that's a benefit will make you feel like
you're at a cinema with a noisy eater
but I don't want to be a noise no you
don't want to hear this volume still low
okay this is a good time to kind of
adjust that to cuz we'll we'll know
because of the talking
so maybe bumping up a bit and then when
the gunshots start happening then we'll
bring it back down because we realize we
went too far
okay hopefully that helps oh god what is
happening Ben what is going on yes
everything's orange oh you're in a wall
oh geez
you're clipped into something that
you're not supposed to be in so God what
do I do
Oh God oh Jesus oh god help me oh crap
you just gotta walk backwards actually
don't take walking instructions for me
cuz I'm I can't well I can see exactly
where you are
uh-uh
help I've already trapped myself uh
you're you're good to walk forward in
real life you're good to kind of move
around oh you're getting close to your
table though thank you
I'm sure you felt though okay hold on
I'm just gonna reset here oh yeah you
need to get out out of the computers the
computers are not things you can stand
inside of this is a treatment oh my god
I can't believe it so this is this is a
downside to room scale of stuff because
you can walk through things and aren't
there well normally you don't like
constantly go back to your you know
computer to adjust for audio yeah that's
fair very good okay let's uh let's move
let's get this thing moving yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I'm not tripping on cables here oh he's
broken yeah thank yesterday anytime
we're that you I did nothing but show up
on look someone who's doing all the
actual work for this and not only did he
do all the work to get this set up all
morning he's also putting himself in a
VR headset for an hour and a half
thanks maybe an hour depending on how
you feel interestingly enough I played
two hours I'm not a person usually get
sick in VR I actually had to use the sit
down option for a bit because it caught
up to me which is odd and has never
happened before but I like it
game sound is much better at least we
can read the subtitle everything's
coming together now that's what it
sounds cool feel like this is really fun
by the way oh yeah it works like really
well I'm still surprised by how well a
lot of that stuff does work okay cool
let's keep going Oh
too close
this'll does a lot
oh man this looks great
oh you want to although the wild thing
was for that for writing on the window
huh is I I went to like by default like
instinct wipe it away with my hand Oh
cuz I didn't want to mess with it it
actually wipes away with your hand where
your your hand is having contact on it
and that was almost too much for me I
was like that's that's real cool oh yeah
that is terrifying in VR that is
absolutely terrifying
what jumping downstairs what jumping
down the stairs
no the the guy in front of me Oh gonna
do it oh I think I must hit that thing
doors are like surprisingly responsive
which is it's like usually that's the
hardest thing in VR I feel like it
always feels awkward yeah I I also like
seeing the half-open ones and not even
messing with the handle and just pushing
them with my hand yeah oh hello
apparently the sound is jittering uh
I've been having that issue I don't know
how to fix that it just kind of does it
sometimes no I'm not sure what I can do
to fix that we may have to write it out
then if it's like unbearable please let
me know and I will do what I can but
yeah let us know if it gets worse or
doesn't stop I'm feeding him I'll look
at him he's so cute those are those
little bug things I like attack you in
in half-life one right yeah yeah
Oh Oh all the game froze for half a
second that was [ __ ] terrifying
got some toggle in-game menu what for oh
okay um do I just keep going
yeah dude I'd say just keep kind of
moving through it however you feel like
okay
does shirt your first time doing it
right yeah yeah
flipping taking at your own pace dude do
your thing I'm almost done with my food
so I can give my full attention
oh no worries so all I'm ready for that
no I almost hurt myself
all right
I've made it I'm done everything's
cleared out no more food I'm feeling
good
let's let's do this also nothing you can
probably change yeah but my previewing
discord has frozen oh so I'm your throws
yeah so I can I can just watch on the
stream I'll just be let me fix it let me
adjust the audio one more time okay so
yeah you have multiple things let's just
group everything let's bundle all of our
fixes yeah let's see if I can fix all
this okay I feel like that's what a lot
of the stream is gonna be Oh probably
yeah hold on one second
so if I just
there we go whoo yeah so now you should
be getting Alex I also think you're its
muted the game yeah oh it's just because
uh I have the if I were to like go back
I'm pretty sure it fix itself for sure
hey I can see now let me think the audio
issue I'm not really sure if I can fix
the crackly stuff let me just lower it a
little bit see if that's at least a
little bit more manageable for people
okay what's back in it get back in it
live again okay let's get these on there
you go
can hear
ah I can't but that's okay I played
through this so I know what they say
okay I'll take it as long as they can
hear as long as as long as everything's
good for people watching that's that's a
man actually I care about I got the up
two-minute video now coming through
discord so I can at least like be on the
same beat as you two so that's also good
yeah that's how long is this gonna take
as long as it needs to you know unless
you're asking how long the game is
because I think it's like 15 hours yeah
Michel beat in 14 yeah and then I saw
Danny
I watched Danny's review on Twitter or
on YouTube he said took him 12 yeah I
liked Danny illustrating his like room
setup yeah that was really good in the
game Mel's really good yeah also I spent
way too much time once I got the gravity
gloves like just oh you know I'm gonna
it's real good apparently there is an
echo now with the audio oh my god really
never ends I think I know why
doctor are you listening now okay hold
on
one more time I don't hear an echo but
I could also be wiling out and not know
what I'm talking about there shouldn't
be one I don't think there is if you got
an echo it might because you have 2
streams open or is if anyone else hears
an echo let me know oh just got put my
hands back on of course like you do okay
um let's see here I need to go this way
so yeah dude there's just something
about being back in the world of like
city 17 that's gay feels for cool yeah I
like it
Aundre says no echo good okay okay
Brandon asked us how her weekend was it
was great I just played Animal Crossing
the whole time yep not the whole time I
also played like a little bit of doom oh
and I also played a little bit of PSO
but a lot of Animal Crossing I did it
whoa apparently it's when the characters
talk it goes I wonder well keeping you
around that's weird I don't know why I
would do it just for the characters that
doesn't make much sense
man oh I do have the sound the sound is
back it just just happened I was like is
I heard like a little musical bump and I
was like oh yeah it's really good wait
there we go can you use walking type
mode for better you can't there are four
different movement options in the game
including just regular kind of fluid
walking movement if you're able to
stomach it
got zapped by that fit combine no no the
worst yeah I can I feel what that the
teleportation kind of takes away from it
it's it's more for accessibility and not
getting sick in VR if you can stomach
the movement it's totally worth it
totally I would agree I also like you've
got like a hybrid one going on maybe
right now but you can like you can jump
but also still walk yeah no I can I have
room skill as an option yeah [ __ ] off
yeah first of a lot of people can't
handle fluid walking as the option just
cuz it your your brain sees that you're
moving forward but you're not actually
moving forward so it feels like your
whole body needs to be in a different
place yeah I can get used to it
I played like all of Resident Evil seven
that way but it's not ideal it for me
when I first like did it initially it
felt kind of like if you've ever stood
like on a beach and kind of stare down
at the water as it like washes up under
the under the shore it's that kind of
feeling where your body kind of store
your eyes see all of the water moving
one way but you're not going with it the
echo is apparently so happening just on
characters I guess
it's entirely possible my mic is picking
up the headphone audio because it's very
might be the headphone audio is very
loud because uh uh he says that it's my
mic picking it up which isn't possible
but I could understand if it were your
laughs picking it up it's definitely my
laughs do you know how to open up like
the steam I don't know how to do it on
index controllers unless you have like a
menu button or something that you can do
hold on I'll do one thing doing this you
can play this sitting down
you totally can have an experience will
be area so it's fun that's what this
this kind of stream is set up fourth
kind of show off the the new game and
also to answer questions cuz there's a
lots of stuff going on is drunk playing
yes I am playing hello he's playing and
he's also running a whole bunch of tech
support all at the same time by himself
okay that should be better
cool okay I hope that it should at this
point solve all the issues think so
hopes brick what's a Wheaton I'm awful
at reading I apologize and also thank
you for correcting me say I do try to
read people's names as well as I can
it's there's a person who I used to hang
out with on the internet a whole bunch
whose name is ah damn so I'm like ah he
got you that's this night got it
sweet Rin apparently that's still echoey
okay if it's still well put the I hate
lessons I don't know what I hate what
you've done it's off screen whatever it
is I might hit my TV I hope not I also
hope not well I guess TV would make
sense cuz you're the opposite side of
your couch so my couch is for reference
we're here you're facing your couch I'm
facing the way this is my face
that's your couch cool okay that's all I
needed now people saying that echo is
worse it's worse
wolf dude I like lowered it how could be
worse these are the questions alright I
could try and fix it um I'm just not
really sure what the issue is okay
rinsing it doesn't sound too bad
what head center say I'm not sure what
would be causing it though so the
headset is the one that's built into the
the VR headset I'm not using that
microphone I'm using a lab yeah using a
headset with with touch controllers or
with index controllers yeah they should
just be getting I literally don't know
what would be causing it though I wonder
if I might have something to do with how
the audio split coming into discord
maybe or is that like a separate deal
I mean I'm muting
that
and you were hearing game Ben I was yeah
okay strange but apparently only having
characters talks like you got can't like
it's only one characters talk you don't
have this tree up on your computer do
you although that would be way too
simultaneous to have that be the case
there are a lot of people also saying
that there isn't an echo but it's
apparently only happens when it talks oh
yeah I'll mute my stream on my end to
listen to it and I'll tell you okay I'm
gonna go back in because I can figure it
out okay pick those hands back up thank
you
[Music]
Oh
it's gonna toss some things around you
know it
ah hello I recognize this place
mm-hmm honestly it's like I get like
some Resident Evil seven vibes right
here yeah all right how's it sound for
you oh yeah I was listening when there
were people talking there's no echo
okay then well I'm just gonna keep going
then I mean it was like a little bit of
a thing it's nothing
I guess it's fixed we're good it's done
solve dude from he's like their boss
from fly the [ __ ] words okay it's
exactly him I love that guy
remembers name I love him it's a good
dude
Darby or something okay it's been a
while but no you don't have to jump from
spot to spot there multiple movement
modes do you do you feel okay enough to
try the smooth movement just to see or I
can try it people seem really adamant
about wanting uh you do the hybrid ones
that you can you can teleport also while
being able to move just to show it off
that's weapons like hybrid oh yeah there
are four different ways to move around
do all sorts of stuff it's a blink is
teleport continuous
I guess this one is this the one I want
movement continuous oh yeah continuous
there you go they only would just by
stepping there's a lot why does Alex
sound like that she has different voice
actress yeah which is weird and I'm not
entirely used to it yet but it's still
kind of close but it's not exactly close
Oh what I can't put my head boo
oh I guess it is a window I thought it
was open for whatever reason and also I
think if you pressed back on your right
stick you might still be able to
teleport if you want to yeah what a
different button yeah okay
so you still have both
yeah the gravity gloves here we go
cool
all right you know how the SCOTUS this
should be a bunch of junk down there
okay so it's not really doing anything
there we go okay
you wear that hat actually you know what
is the weirdest thing there are people
that can talk about how the voices were
high-pitched and I was like no we're
just kidding you're like Pola again the
voices are actually high-pitched wait
and in the game like the voice the
voices are higher pitch than they should
be
I don't know how that's happening you
guys are hearing that I'm hearing it now
I I wanted to make sure before I brought
it up it sounds perfectly normal to me
it's I don't know what it's it's doing
it's not it's not bad it's not but it's
definitely not the way it's supposed to
look like fists aim and then pull it
back a little lower it's kind of weird
I count it cool no I didn't even realize
it either I'm until someone mentioned it
I was like okay I've gotta like make
sure I genuinely don't know when I find
that strange the VR streaming is well
okay there's just a lot it's not bad
apparently I dude that's a that's a new
one for me okay there we go
yeah nope and I bet you're gonna weigh
us use the the right stick so it like
kind of moves or your inventory
depending on how you like you click it
in no you just haven't gotten tutorial
on it yet I guess it'll a little shorter
well geez I'm sorry about the the whole
echoey thing I don't know what's up with
that or the now the high-pitch thing
that's a new one yeah it's it's not bad
it's it's totally fine a bunch of people
in the chat actually said they didn't
even notice it until I pointed it out
excellent everybody can thank me for
making a mess of it well apologies
everyone if this is not a ideal stream
[Music]
unusual circumstances and whatnot
uh just because I want to say her name
and also because you bring up a good
point ass bar SPO brings up a good point
that's not what the the game actually
sounds like and the game actually does
run pretty well even with my experience
too yeah here's the thing yeah I
apologies if you guys are experiencing
weird for me it is running perfectly it
sounds perfect
for whatever reason it's just it's
sending it to you guys as being weird
there's something going on in coding
there's something going on in the
transfer but what I'm hearing and seeing
is like perfect also I'm really stuck
then I got to say a spare today so we're
killing it on all fronts Oh gross yeah
the first obvious he is something
hmm
and 7017 so cool people saying the
stream is good and they're excited to
watch a play awesome it takes a little
bit to get used to but it's cool yeah
once you once you get it like you just
start kind of tossing stuff up and
retouching it yeah it's not bad walking
around I'll say that yeah it did sort of
catch up to me eventually but I wasn't I
wasn't doing too bad that something I'd
want to do long term but it's absolutely
perfect for sitting though because then
I guess in my situation if I'm sitting
down my mind's like ah you're not
actually moving or just playing a game
and it's really close to your eyes so
don't worry about oh there we go
solve those puzzles okay
oh did you know your PC specs off the
top of your head I have a 27 D super I
believe in for my card and I couldn't
tell you my processor I think it's an i7
okay I is using a vive Pro headset with
index controllers yes which works pretty
well so if you're somebody who already
owns a vibe and doesn't want to upgrade
to the full like you know index
experience cuz I should it cost like
$1,000 I would maybe recommend upgrading
to the controllers because I think these
controllers are significantly better
than the ones on the the vibe default so
you finally adjusted to the like letting
go of things I have okay to the point
where then when I went back to the vibe
controllers it felt odd cuz like you get
used to like the way you're gripping
stuff but the vibe controllers it's it's
a button again yeah yeah weird
is this the reference is not the rift I
was playing on the rift
you've been playing on the rift right
we're actually working on a video yeah
where we're going to we have everyone in
the office testing Alex on all the
different major headset so oh I just
smacked my TV I think how is your hand
okay hurts a little bit yikes
oh well it was been habit at some point
but now we're gonna test with every
major headset so I'm testing with the
vibe you're testing with the rift
michael is testing with index and then
Jake is testing with the oculus quest
which will be an interesting one you had
to get like a cord for it and everything
yeah
I do really like the idea finger
tracking and I almost bought index
controllers for myself but the touch
controllers they're like half step for
it because it tracks your your middle
index and thumb which is pretty cool but
that's horrifying yeah I didn't I wasn't
like more than headcrabs I wasn't
looking forward to seeing barnacles in
in VR that's not a thing I'm here for as
if there's a question of either VIPRE
oculus I'd say get whatever you can to
play it you can't really go wrong with
either one obviously one's more
expensive and probably is a better
option I would say get what you can I
mean I definitely look forward to our
video where we'll hopefully kind of
break down the pros and cons of each one
but I would say that from what I've
heard it seems like it is a playable
game in every different headset and I
think it's just it seems like it's a
game that's worth playing no matter what
you have yeah I don't feel like I have a
cheapened experience using my oculus so
far at all and I bet you're having a
good setup right now oh yeah yeah the
vibe works great well especially because
you can combine the vibe with like the
index controllers is a huge difference
your test Sony's VR headset for Alex
honey I'm sure someone will find a way
to get it to work but that's that's not
a it's not a deal I think yeah I don't
like it and then when they pull like if
you accidentally walk into one your
screen starts flashing red and it's not
a fun time it's really not there we go
now this isn't bad just walking around
it seems like the chat prefers it
yeah I think it just makes for a more
presentable watchable experience that's
fair because otherwise you're just kind
of shooting around all over the place no
don't go in there don't do that I'm
second no you're too close oh I thought
you got like poison or something for
half a second those uh there's a lot we
have all these things I can pick up
excellent it's also weird to play a VR
shooting game where you don't have to
hold the gun yeah I was I was messing
with Pavlov the other day just to
practice and that game is like intense
the way your guns work it's cool it's
super cool but like holy [ __ ] very like
bone works is still real intense that
horseshoes and hand-grenades game is
pretty good oh [ __ ] oh yeah this game is
all about tossing and throwing things
physics for days that's a half-life baby
[Music]
follow my nose okay look
spooky so like how everyone I've seen do
this part does kind of the same like
poke it thing so it's it's hard to pick
things up and pick pick like a dead
dudes up which makes sense
open this oh maybe I have to do I have
to stand on top of that box yeah stack
that thing up you know it okay this is
kind of weird a little awkward down here
there you go perfect flawless yep Oh God
so gross you're kind of close to your TV
but as a heads up thank you again I saw
you I saw you dipping real fast to pick
them up I'm like you might call it the
TV is this the couch yes that's the
couch and you are in the middle of your
you're up that's the couch have a seat
perfect thank you right feel like I
might be hearing a hint of an Australian
accent from the voice actor for Alex
it's possible I actually haven't looked
anything up about them the only person
who I I know is is the guy near your
headset all the time forget his name
right now sees he's from flight of the
conchords like we were talking about
earlier there we go
I'm surprised how much stuff you're
still actually like physically going to
pick up because I just as soon as I got
the gravity gloves I was just left and
right pulling things to me yeah right
what oh yeah I didn't get out of I
didn't even see that that's too much
that's a really good okay here we are
oh no also I don't know if I needed to
see the flippin creature getting
liquefied every time Fallone nasty I'm
not a fan I mean I definitely appreciate
it it's an interesting detail but I
wasn't calling Rosner be Australian I
was just saying he's the only one that I
recognize or know hmm okay I need to put
a thing in here ah there's a puzzle to
be solved I see
oh hello oh this is weird
oh that was it yeah yeah those are cool
you gotta connect the points what's oh
it's topical I hate that yeah yeah you
want it you're ready for another thing
that you might not like what you notice
what's inside of those things that you
just pulled up well you're gonna have to
spin it you're probably gonna see it
[Music]
it's just a whole bunch of parts from
different things oh that's the one that
got me that was no I was like what is
this oh wait a minute what am I even
doing with this you've got a focal point
the laser from the thing through it
Oh like a part that it goes through
there you go yeah yeah yeah cool which
difficulty we're playing on I think this
is just the default
that's cool I mean I I wouldn't want to
go too crazy my first time through
no definitely not I'm curious I'm
curious to see if this games got like a
cool replayability deal to it kind of
check some some more stuff out do some
more challenging why are his hands
reversed my hands
but I don't think they are Oh hold on
wait a minute let me it's because I'm
I'm seeing it camera stuff it's camera
stuff I'm not gonna try to oh your hands
on your first my hands are first your
hand server because in the video that
people see of you it's it's mirrored
wait it's mirrored yes so when you put
up your right hand so I see I see on my
screen it's your right hand but on the
stream it comes through as your left
what why so then when you're lifting up
your left it look these are just dumped
technical things it's okay we're fine
also interesting thing to point out I
don't get this why is it doing things
like that I don't know this is gross
it's area that you're in it's like HUD
normal no you're HUDs normal the game's
fine it's just the camera with you is
the other way oh oh my camera yeah yeah
oh I thought it was like the game was
referred no I was yeah it was a okay got
it
okay cool I can live with that man I get
some some combat here Oh David's
counting on you tripping over your couch
I already don't punch myself so you know
yeah you hit your TV twice so far I
think it wouldn't be a vr stream without
accidentally hitting something though
yeah
I'm new welcome darkness I'm glad that
you're here and I hope you're having a
good day
it's Monday we're quite half life Alex a
VR stream from home how how we're
managing to do this I don't know this
has been an interesting stream adventure
right it's too big
there goes on top of everything else I
also forgot that after I'd finished my
food I could just turn on my camera
I don't get em oh yeah what is happening
you're disconnected you know what is it
was too much my camera was too much okay
well good I guess
oh there you go you got over your
shoulder I'll try this one more time
uh-uh apologies that run there we go
now now everything's the way it should
be now now we're streaming for real
we're streaming for real I also like how
because I got kicked out of the call it
it just showed like the stream that you
were sending me of the game in my spot
oh did it split second yeah it probably
that make sense yeah we're doing it now
show off my disgusting quarantine beard
that I haven't been maintaining I
probably should do something with I'm
pretty sure the CDC actually said that
we shouldn't have beards oh now at some
point so see how that goes
like I'm rocking that beard you know it
it's a real mess over here move in see
you're smart about this as soon as I saw
those barrels I was like oh I'm gonna
shoot them all and it didn't do anything
because what you're supposed to do my
vibe wasn't thinking I I spent my entire
day I mentioned it earlier spent the
entire day yesterday getting my VR
headset fixed in working again only to
realize after I'd uninstall software it
means - what you could put this mask on
yeah you can wear masks and hats and I
don't know if they give you any benefit
but they're there you're actually not
working oh it was good can't like crack
open the yeah be nice to be all the grab
things were two hands but anyway I'd
reinstalled and installed the software
like multiple times and then eventually
I realized that it was just that the
cable in the headset itself was a little
bit out and I'd spent the entire day see
him up with this pipe I hope so heard a
lot
never really cared about VR games come
out brush need to play it's half life is
it half as good as I've dreamed it would
be
it's a stockings on that before we
started the stream it's giving me kind
of like a half life to kind of feel
where when we first played that it was
it was wild that Gordon could like pick
things up and move things around there
was a really cool physic system and the
combine soldier yelling pick up that
can' and you had to pick it up and
actually put it inside the garbage but
like actually meal to be in half life
and interact with all that stuff with
your actual not your actual hands but
your like a representation of your hands
it's it feels good and it feels like
it's a real good set for I've only
played like two hours though so I can't
like say definitively about I really
like what I've actual like it is actual
magazine rule so I do actually have to
yeah yet so you got a got empty all the
shots out if you if you throw one out
before you're done you're waste ammo I
also appreciate the way the glove stuff
is laid out because you can do the like
what you're doing right now weird
actually
glues your your hand to the gun yeah but
you're just like distinctively do it I
mean also if you take like the the
middle your solid three like snake
eaters thing where you rest your hand on
top of your other hand you'll have the
read out right in front of your face and
you can see where your health and ammo
matter her at all times like doing that
kind of thing I ended up doing that
which was kind of nice any headcrabs yet
maybe not yet I think but there were
things happening red barrels we need to
shoot them a lot of video games in my
background I do they're all video game
boxes and like old games
there we go yeah you gotta move it so
it's it's uh search these nope how's the
story
I haven't played enough to kind of know
where the story is gonna go but I've
heard that it's good if if you want to
hear thoughts from someone who is
actually played through the whole thing
we actually have a review up on this
YouTube channel
I also recommend it it there are no
spoilers in it it does a great job
talking about the mechanics how it all
works in VR and did a really good job
just getting me kind of excited to play
me too
so I I I can't recommend it enough okay
my gun should have a scope on it now
yeah you see it's kind of getting that
shape to it now to look like Alex's gun
oh wow
it'll make sense that's really cool it's
all coming together yeah I keep hearing
a lot about the story paying off that's
what Michael is saying Michael the don't
worry the review is spoiler free we
don't show anything we don't talk
specifics but Michael talks about how
the story has this like amazing
conclusion and just like the payoff is
like insanely good Michael wants to do
like a spoiler I'm ready for it and
everything I'm ready to cry in my VR
headset something I'm ready for
something happen yeah okay so I got that
guy there Michael Reed says solid video
review quasar saying they're gonna check
it out after the stream heck yeah got
him really far behind
yeah we're spending a lot of time
getting the the stream set up and making
sure yeah we don't start we don't start
till 2:00 yeah so I mean for for being
in like an hour and 15 it's not too bad
yeah we go a little longer today if we
want to
I feel like you want to go a little bit
longer with
the VR hekia I feel bad because of all
the tech issues sure I'm as long as
you're down for it all oh hang out are
you so that's the other thing
index controllers bump into each other
they do but the vibe controllers bump
into each other even more so this is
already better yeah don't slap the
zombie ah this dangerous I mean could
could you actually run up and just kind
of do like a just working that is
genuinely terrifying yeah I uh I don't
like it I really like food yeah like
there I feel like this is giving already
like half-life things like a new new new
perspective you know right yeah oh so
was it Snerd snow gave oh I hope I said
your name in a way that makes sense I
was talking about how they wish there
was a better way to move around but then
they realize that there are 15 minutes
behind and they're caught up now and
they realize that we've switched over to
smooth yeah smooth move in so welcome so
the lifetime I'm glad that you found us
Brennan wants to know what we're
thinking of streaming tomorrow I think
uh Persia's on fright Persia would be on
I don't know what is being thought of
being stream tomorrow bleeding edges out
mmm I might have to make some time to
miss her I'm gonna try and make a little
bit of time to mess around with it I
really enjoy playing that game more than
I thought I would tell a team swap
please give me an HTC vive if I could
give everyone in the Chateau vive if it
were a thing I could do
I do it hurt I don't have a vibe dude
this is the offices vibe that I like
grabbed before we got kicked out of the
office and told to go home because I was
like well we got to play Alex yeah if we
give it I would but I can't
unfortunately
cool I'll admit that [ __ ] freaked me
out oh yeah I remember hearing about
about that Dave and London the the
screams for the zombies when they get
lit on fire in half-life 2 oh yeah
they're terrifying yeah they're all like
played in Reverse and just it's a lot
yeah you almost got jumped by that
headcrab you almost let it happen
damn look how nasty you look right
that's good
yeah they like I feel dead crabs are
genuinely more terrifying in this one
they're not like just like doing the way
they kind of are in the original okay
they're like when they die and they
throw the front legs up and fall back
love it pretty good
how does this look on a first gen oculus
rift that's what you have right I I
think I have an iteration afterwards I'm
not sure but I mean I'm actually not
sure what a first gen oculus it is it
have to be a retail thing maybe I do
well first gen was like there's like so
many there's like the Kickstarter
prototype there's like when I think
first gen I think like really really bad
old like being shown like a like a
slender knockoff but in VR and
everything was just green and the screen
boring was awful yeah yeah like my my
roommate in college kick-started the
oculus and got like
the og death kits like that's what I
think yeah I think it's like ogee but
I'll I'll say I'm on my ocular if I
don't know if it's a if it's a base one
or I don't that came with the touch
controllers it works really well I'm
gonna let the next one jump on me cuz I
won't know what happens good
I think bone work stole the headcrab
character oh definitely
I'm pretty sure those guys were trying
to make something half life related and
they realize they had to like skin the
game to look different Oh cuz they're
they're headcrabs are just VR headsets
with legs oh geez get the the gravity
gloves are the best oh that's a piece of
glass are like the best kind of excuse
for having like VR grabbing technology
from remote distances and they're so fun
to use every time so anyway try juggling
in VR yeah oh yeah not not any good at
it
just like in real life but
there you go I'm not doing it I'm not
doing it the way you should be doing it
because I I mean behave you you've
juggled things though that's that's good
trying to get used to like doing that
quickly if I need to hello it's an eye
it's aged for half life I love it
can you use a Deadhead crab as a weapon
I wonder if you can actually like whip
it around at something so I really want
to try it that was like that video where
they like used the chair and they were
like they like block the headcrab and
like pushed it that way like I want to
mess with that kind of stuff
yeah I feel like you've got to be put
into a scenario where you've got like
chairs or something around you yeah I
threw your next like an explosive barrel
at a zombie when I was playing and that
worked pretty well aha puzzle
look at all those cool paintings I love
this because this is all half-life one
yeah she got like like the lion whatever
they call ant lions ant lions the Board
of God
there's the Striders that's the that's
the baby boss thing Inc wants to know if
you feel sick at all
right now no I'm actually feeling okay
thank you yeah but you got like that's
like the giant baby head thing you
[ __ ] the end that's the the Gorgon
that you fight yeah yeah and there's
there's our boy
that's Gordon Freeman that's cool
yes it's it's real neat anyway like that
stuff there's a puzzle
Need for Speed legend wants to know do
we prefer the gravity gunner the gravity
gloves I mean the gravity gloves are
work perfectly for VR they they feel
tactile I I kind of curious how the
gravity gun would feel like holding it
in VR and being like yeah yeah I kind of
like how the gravity gloves I don't
think there is powerful cuz they're
meant to be earlier technology right
yeah these are like precursors yeah so
like they they don't look you can't pick
up things big things with them yet it
seems unless something happens later on
in the story but as it stands you just
kind of like you could pick up small
stuff in that like feeling of kind of
mind controlling something into your
hands mmm hasn't gotten old yet like it
okay line the eye up with the wall to
find the code
I'll back here
well that is not here anymore uh maybe
there's there's something going on with
the wall the oh sure leave mural yeah
there's like this weird energy
stand up on top of there yeah okay hmm
is there any kind of vibration on the
set you're using or like phantom
vibration being done in the VR
environments make it feel more tactile
yeah there's a little bit there's a
little bit of VR of
vibration on the controller this is kind
of subtle but I think that kind of works
like it's just sort of adds a little bit
to it yeah you don't want it to be like
overkill or anything yeah okay um maybe
Michael is Michael in the chat he said
he might pop in the chat I haven't seen
him yet he's originally supposed to be
on the stream but he wasn't able to to
make it work which is okay oh sure
ash workman says new to the channel love
the stream how long are we gonna extreme
for today normally we'd be going for
about five more minutes but Jean Luc's
feeling spicy I'm gonna keep going I
mean if I don't know how many people are
watching but if people are into it I'm
down to just keep going today yeah we
did start a little bit late because of
technical issues so we can't technically
we owe you guys a little bit of extra
stream too so yeah I guess we'll go
until John Luke doesn't feel great or we
find like a good dropping off point yeah
I would like to not spend too much time
on this puzzle though maybe yeah do you
mind picking Michael uh I can do just
that cuz he said he would you know on
the side of something you can mess with
someone saying as a handle okay
[Music]
cuz yeah I don't want to I don't want
waste too much time Michael was kind of
mentioning to me about like you know
making sure I wasn't stuck at a puzzle
too long cuz like ya know I think I got
it
oh never mind I figured it out it's that
thing over there
cool all right tell him nevermind is it
everyone we got it
I like how I like how in students are
some of us she's like alright what
excuse me wait he was like that yeah he
said he wouldn't help he might be in the
middle it's all wrong we figured it out
we cracked the code
alright now we're gonna do some spooky
stuff
woo so this is this is unknown area for
me because I stopped right before that I
happens I like this I like this a lot
hello go as the video feed of the guy
with controllers and headset mirrored
yet sits mirrored but this is fine
apologies
hello headcrabs headcrabs - oh god I
love how they use the word B yeah
look at that animation I love it yeah
he's great
I'm just catching up on a whole bunch of
stuff since I had slack open cuz I'm an
awful person we gotta go save more - got
sounds like a good worthy cause Oh
Michaels here hi Michael for the people
in chat who don't know Michael is the
wonderful person who reviewed this game
for us so if you have any questions he's
the guy to ask but we were stuck on a
puzzle a second ago and then just as
soon as I sent the message to you
Jenna solved it but I'm glad that you're
here it's good to see you
in
oh if I can I run across your friends I
will see what I can do I really like how
he talks with his hands just everywhere
thanks dude
all right bye
well see you later
Oh some people asking to have the game
volume turned up a little bit I think
it's just cuz there's a lot of talking
happening but you might be I might yeah
I think it might be worth it's it's fine
I'll try to talk less with me
first snack
how long has the total gameplay
estimated I've been here and hearing a
lot of people say around 15 hours yeah
Michael took 14 yeah hey if solving by
picking random numbers isn't solving
then there's a lot of puzzles I haven't
ever actually solved but that hat on I I
want to know if there are benefits to
wearing things there yeah yeah that's
what I'm talking about
it's like a blue shell there we go I'm
ready and I got my boots
okay so their shells are immune I
appreciate that they introduced them
behind a fence yeah give you time to go
how do i there we go forth
okay I need a thing hello oh you go
there's a lot of a lot of zombies that
you run into oh man
it's Evan - two waters langer in the
chat
hi there long time fan first time caller
uh when you say we'll see another half
of life thank you
right today is the day as a rending it's
the red letter day it is it's it's here
a new half a half of life here for all
of us people are calling for you to
reload but all right over here oh nice I
look away for a second because like I
technically my waste bullets like you
know she wastes bullets if you don't
shoot them all so I'm trying to be like
actually treated like a real gun yeah
magazines are real things in this Wow
Evans gave me the year was Luigi's
Mansion sounds like our Evan hey stealth
uh all the way from Russia watching good
to see ya
greetings so many so many cool people
hang out in the chat they love it I'm
glad that you're able to get this VR
stuff sorted - still it's still super
amazing to me just how we even have a
stream still going even when we're all
working from home right now
oh-oh-oh it's go real fast come on oh my
gosh this is really hard for some reason
oh it's weird to spin a thing that
you're not actually holding yeah it's
like not doing it quite the way I want
it to you gonna like follow its its
physics rules even though you're not in
the same physical space there we go man
I'm doing it again I'm looking at SLAC
again because everyone keeps slacking
things there it is
whoo cool awesome all right okay this
way that way or that way what you think
um I think that way this way yeah it's
got kind of a cool ominous look to it
there's a lot of dead guys and lights
though the light is kind of what drew me
to it I guess
Green's from Ohio hekia the Midwest
sounded off I love it I grew up in
Ferguson the regular stuff that comes
out sway more relaxed just feels like
I'm watching when everybody's playing
new game yeah I I always try to kind of
it's my favorite way to do a stream just
kind of hanging out talking sure no good
to do it with to because I think a lot
of people are just nope nope oh God
yikes oh that was terrifying yeah VR
isn't a thing that's readily available
for everyone and especially with VR
shortages if you have the money for it
but just can't find one yeah not
everyone's you know a lot of people are
half my fans but not necessarily able to
play half-life so I think it's uh makes
sense a lot of people are gonna wanna
see what's going on with it oh my god
that's terrifying yeah I'm sad to see
Peter go too I'm I'm gonna miss him but
I know I'll see him see him around
michael says don't waste shotgun shells
with two exclamation points yeah I guess
I should upgrade the shotgun oh hello
from Okinawa people are all over the
place I love it
oh man I'm close to enough
Oh Indiana to love it locked in people
have people all over the place that's
that's another thing I love about
streaming is just seeing people from all
over
everybody loves games we're all we're
all hanging out think I'm full up but
I'll do it anyway okay
cool
it's South Africa turkey Ireland Chicago
North Carolina [ __ ] it's people
everywhere you're still over here doing
with headcrabs jumping it that was like
a sign jump I'm heading back down oh I
look I like they let you kind of just
jump it you don't have to climb back
yeah it's kinda nice it's also weird
that you can even heal with either hand
oh well I was I always I always thought
you had to use the left one because it
had the actual model you're on it and
then I accidentally did it with my right
and I was like oh this is good don't you
much the in game son yeah it's the game
it's a delicate balance are you guys is
it weird for you it's like the game's
jittering for me um I don't see it on my
thing wow this is like really weird
that's the type of stuff that really
messes with your head to to New Mexico
Malaysia
oh geez New York oh my god wow this is
like bad la prima we can open the yellow
boxes Oh
oh yeah those are the supply boxes yeah
cool peanuts I pick up little peanuts
nope Oh Michael can see it I couldn't
see it in my little my small preview but
apparently it was coming through on the
stream oh don't tell myself doing that
it's possible that's funny
dang impressive I guess load this
autosense [ __ ] alright
oh that jitteriness oh god it would be
really cool if we got mods for
what if we just ran the whole thing like
what if we had VR Garry's Mod VR
counter-strike VR add a defeat just run
it all the way through VR ricochet
ricochet - is a VR game I'm getting so
excited I need to like look away to yell
okay whole again from Russia it's got
into the videos or videos about Zelda
those are very good video welcome those
L videos are why they subscribed and
they came into our stream and that's how
they got here I'm glad that you're here
and I'm glad that you enjoy our zelda
videos i'm glad that you subscribed and
you know what this is a good opportunity
uh anyone else who's having a good time
I hope that you also subscribe so you
don't miss a single stream we do because
we we're still streaming every weekday
at 2 p.m. Pacific all sorts of things
new games VR games somehow we've managed
to make that work and John Luke and I
usually do a show every Friday where we
play games with you guys last week we
played doom this week we're thinking of
Animal Crossing website yeah we're just
gonna like open up one of our villages
and just be like hey come hang out come
on over hang out we'll do some fishing
that kind of thing yeah yeah
of course it'd be a vr mod for Garry's
Mod already I haven't looked at Gary's
mom in a long time I most of my time
playing was before the 1.0 came out but
that games come such a long way okay
looks like 30fps must be dizzying yeah
it's better now but before it was like
acting up yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the
good [ __ ]
it really is his head Bob Jones wants to
know what fruit we had when we started
our villages cherries
I had pears but within the first day I
ended up getting everything I need hit
you up for Paris you sent me that text
and I totally meant to hit you up about
it and then I got like wrapped up in my
VR stuff and I forgot that's okay but
you know I got stacks so I can I can
definitely give you one yeah pears for
days oh ho that's one of those hard to
hard to kill ones I don't like it Oh
going some peaches pears and orange
trees from other different song I love
how how easily everything kind of came
together fruit wise for me I was real
worried for a bit
did you just dude that was awesome you
flipped him over so you like deflected
him with this and then just shot it what
is that what were you holding it's uh
their shells like the most disgusting
shells came off I don't like it
anyway
I want to play with his cherries are
there lemons I'm wondering if there are
a whole bunch more fruits that I haven't
seen yet because I think there's only
the five at least for that one mile but
yeah so I got that achievement for it
but I'm like where are the bananas in
the persimmons in
I got away I guess I want to go that way
are we somewhat actual fruit know what
I'm about Oh kind of oh oh that looks
like it stopped for a second it's did
that was incredibly nauseating holy [ __ ]
yeah if you wanted to take a second
reorient okay now but for a brief moment
yeah all of a sudden the chat just kind
of subtly shifted to animal crossing
talk hey everyone it's true so I
apologize if I was talking about proof
doesn't make sense if you're playing but
you know purses that she's downloading
animal crossing right now hi cow source
which finally came in heck yeah
welcome to animal crossing also grats on
getting a switch finally yeah now's a
good time to have one oh yeah they're
coconuts those those are the other ones
yes to come from the islands I've got a
bunch of cool palm trees growing on my
beach now they're actually kind of good
kind of kind of surprised and Source
engine it's the it's the source 2 engine
yeah in it there are times when like
especially in the beginning I was
walking down hallways like it kind of
kind of felt like a realistic hallway I
don't know what's going on with that guy
shot away oh man
so this is the first source to game then
uh sort of I think like dota 2
technically like runs on source 2 to
some degree okay but yes this is sort of
their big source to showcase I would say
it looks great
well muscles for me is not only how all
those are the poisonous ones no I don't
like those huh no no excuse me is just
sitting there
oh I apparently never you just drop in
you're able oh this is great
oh man that went really well
I'm sure that looked amazing high
quality gameplay it was it was
surprising to say the least
oh my god okay you're not dead anyway
we're good game preference for VR gamers
what's the best so far in your opinion
uh I think this is definitely like a
contender for one of the best PR games
I've played oh yeah you play more of it
um other than that is kind of just
playing a whole bunch of smaller games I
really like Robo recall though that was
like my first vr game that I played
played and it really stuck with me yeah
I was gonna say it doesn't look like it
brought you down to one HP when you got
hit by those poisoned headcrabs and
that's yeah I think they changed the way
they work they can duck out of the way
it's that that physicality being in VR
[Music]
Black Mesa runs on a later version of
source 1 not source - ok that makes it
yes yes has anyone played Zegna we're
rip we're streaming it was one of the
last rooms he did before I kick things n
the other day it's good fun
and I'm trying to think of other vo come
back out here oh my god I get that way
that's why okay right so I need to hold
all these I'm getting slack messages
left and right
oh okay well come on what's resin used
for so that's that's how you a person so
many of them do you just it's a shooting
gallery you gotta you gotta get in there
and do the thing I'll be I you you like
3d print upgrades for your gun with it
it's like a resource three bullets
turquoise end but my PCs to bed oh no
Draven I'm sorry this that's no good at
all [ __ ]
uh-uh I'll just run away okay we're
going I'm there's so many conversations
happening I just want to have life okay
boom house weed oh here we go it's good
that's good this is fine
okay headcrabs bumping into walls and
falling over something I never knew I
need to see ya is gonna say it's kind of
hilarious
the like having them just fling
themselves
[Music]
you can choose say yeah so there are
four different movement options like
Fredrik saying you can teleport you can
continuously move like John Lucas doing
now you can do sort of like a weird kind
of not entirely teleport but a smooth I
forget exactly how to describe there are
there four different options you can
play sitting down you can play standing
up there's a whole bunch of
accessibility options for how you want
there's really cool yeah oh just all of
a sudden my brain just stopped working
because I'm I'm in like three different
conversations all oh god
this is genuinely terrifying I'm using
my my original oculus rift and I you
still have access to all the same
movement options it's it's all pretty
much the same thing just it comes down
to preference cuz I know there are some
people who can't handle the fluid
movement so having the teleports a good
option for them Oh
it's nice watching have fun love your
hey love you too stealth I'm glad that
you could hang out I hope you have a
good rescue day well why did you talk
all the time in game I'm assuming you're
talking about me unless you're talking
about Rhys Darby talking but talking cuz
I'm answering you guys's stuff we're
just kind of hanging out with you or
conveying messages to John Luke because
he can't see the chat yes
is there no melee I don't like melee
some dudes didn't seem to be working
which is kind of a weird oversight for a
game made by valve in in half-life yeah
like where's my crowbar yeah yet you
lose all of your weapons except for the
crowbar Gordon leans over and tosses it
to you it's a real Resident Evil type of
situation except instead of a rocket
launcher it's a crowbar whoa
but you do have a syringe if you want to
heal that is a good call
oh I did not realize how low I was yes
yeah pull that out of here on your wrist
yeah thank you thank you
those are boo gotcha oh I would care
from waiting shotguns you know sometimes
it calls for that you know
this is uh this is an interesting part
because you it's it's like completely
dark
got him on I get the other one or didn't
get him I think there's two of them
having the flashlight on your other hand
is an interesting thing too yeah cuz
they're kind of balancing that great
stream guys at 7:00 a.m. here in
Malaysia oh shoot your state you're
staying up late or early at this point
what hekia we have gone in an extra half
over to worth mentioning just sure to
open the door into your face yeah oh
yeah see it is four o'clock
probably gonna call pretty soon then all
right
that's Ashe wants to know what your name
is I also realize we never do intros
when we first started I mean I I don't
think so we were too excited about
getting the VR stuff sorted out but the
person who's playing in the VR headset
is duis while they're talking is John
Luke E is a cool tech wizard who has
managed to get our streams running and
is also your VR chaperone for the day
I'm Ben I'm just here because I'm
looking at the chat but we usually do a
show on Fridays where we play games with
you guys it's kind of our deal
but John Luke usually puts together all
the videos you guys see and my job is
publishing them yeah
oh shoot Brandon thanks for hanging out
and have a good rest of your day
looking forward to seeing you tomorrow
oh you can throw things enemies you
can't it doesn't seem like you can punch
them but you can definitely throw things
I see using a valve index that he's
using the index controllers but with a
vive Pro heads that is correct
so a little bit of like a mix deal but
it's working pretty well
whoo well I hear some sounds good sounds
bad song doesn't hear I hear combine
sounds mmm don't like that
I'm just really excited to see that
fully leveled up gun that's a real big
thing you keep holding down cause he's
like stuck in there oh no a nice VR
headsets 10k in Turkey holy geez 10th
hole that's so much oh my god the good
one just came on for a while hey coming
out for a little while is better than
not coming out at all
Jay I'm glad that you were able to hang
out for a bit yeah thanks for joining
when do you guys stream so we stream
every weekday at 2 p.m. Pacific John
Luke and I every Friday for sure
sometimes will step in to do stuff
during the week but um that you got yeah
Ritchie and you got Persia and just a
whole bunch of cool people always
playing things here all the time so you
don't want to miss any of them that's
what I'm saying you definitely want to
subscribe so you get email notifications
and you know whatever it happens you
also get to know whatever our videos go
up like our video review for half-life
Alex oh you should definitely watch it's
a very good video
okay here we go
all right nope ow
are you the junk subscribe doesn't show
is live streaming it should send you a
notification YouTube subscribes are
weird sometimes like they should but
when it works right it'll let you know
do we have Garry's Mod do I haven't
played it in a while though but to have
it
thanks for the streams thanks for
subscribing thank thank you guys for
first subscribe means a lot
cuz that like I mean obviously it's good
because it adds to a number but the
thing that gets me really jazzed about
it does it means that there's a
possibility I'm gonna see you again
that means you liked our [ __ ] enough
that you wanted to see more which is a
very positive thing for us yeah
do I have a channel I do but I don't do
anything there's a bunch of like joke
uploads on it that it's not worth really
look yeah I'm kind of the same I used to
have it stuff on it but not really
whoa see that's the part Witter handles
anywhere on this that's the next thing
we need to do I treat random nonsense
every day it's disgusting
yeah I also hate manhacks to be honest
they're loud and they kind of are just
faster probably easier to kill them this
since here you're actually aiming but a
little bit yeah they're uh little blow
buzzers killing arounds to rate this
game out of 10 that's a fun funny
question you should check out our review
yeah what did Michael give it at $9.99
so our official GameSpot score is a 9
out of 10 which if the couple hours I've
played are any indication I believe it
yeah goodbye
that never gets old
it looks good even when you watch it
happen and it feels even better when you
do it like just pull and stuff from
across the room oh that looked like it
probably wasn't good those are those
blood splatters or something else what
you should be dead you should have
caught it caught him like out of the air
just toss him back down to the ground
tell if they died something well
will this change VR sales I don't think
it'll ever like I don't know if there
will ever be if half life isn't the
thing that moves VR units more than it
already has the only other thing is just
making VR more accessible there are tons
of people who can't play this who would
love to but VR is just not an easy thing
to break into it's not readily available
it's not an easy thing to set up I know
it's already like pushed VR sales more
than most things but yeah like whether
it's it's gonna do it on a large scale
who knows I would say probably not
yeah but it'll be interesting to see how
many more people do get VR and kind of
stick with it like I want I want them to
show like numbers release numbers around
when the game came out or or when the
the pre-order went up to see like how
what percentage more people actually
bought headsets right Final Fantasy 14
VR is the one Michael knows Steve more
14 you are getting close to your TV
again but oh thank you yeah
I'm trying my best to kind of keep an
eye on it but no I really appreciate
that okay
Lavie are just waiting for payday payday
2 has VR oh that's actually pretty good
and you can you can play with people who
don't have PR unless he met he's waiting
for his payday so that he could buy the
game oh yeah that makes more sense
the fun fact payday is VR it's pretty
alright but also yeah I understand
waiting for an actual payday so you can
actually buy a VR headset man that's
wild
no sound effects I think it just might
be quiet so vote no Jesus that
jitteriness holy [ __ ] maybe maybe your
computer's telling you that you've been
you've been in this for too long I think
it is I think it has it's been a good
solid two hours in it okay well yeah
maybe this is where we'll stop that I'm
trying to find like a good stopping
point you don't want to just leave in
the middle of this like tunnel yeah
don't drink the water
Windsor Ontario Canada don't have a VR
place to enforce it but I think should I
just stop here I mean if you feel like
it's a it's a good place to do it it's
entirely up to you
sure you know what why not yeah let's
stop here it's it's starting to it's
being real jittery on me in a way that's
uh getting a little hard hey we would
like what 20 minutes of bonus streaming
here that's where's my couch
it's you're right that's why right in
front of you this is thankful you'll get
there just keep going yet you you're
almost there
thank you there you go yeah okay
[Music]
I'm sure that if if we could we just go
all day anyway hello
there you go whoa you got you got some
powerful anime like VR headset hair
going on yeah oh my god Wow well thank
you everybody for joining us thank ya on
this dream I hope you had a good time I
hope you got a taste of half-life Alex I
need to take a shower don't be a fool
stay in school play out cuz I play dog
and Rob thank you for hanging out I
appreciate all of you stay safe wash
your hands a whole bunch don't go
outside that's pretty much it
cool alright thanks guys see you next
time bye everybody have a good day
you